exclusive behind the scenes look at
music's biggest night that is the 64th
annual grammy awards as part of our road
to the grammy series we're hearing from
the executive producers of this year's
show as well as brothers osborne who
have received two nominations this year
anthony mason met up with the duo during
the first day of rehearsals at the mgm
grand in las vegas and that is where
anthony is this morning anthony good to
see you good morning
good morning you all this is where the
nominees are going to be sitting come
sunday night here in vegas
back in january of course omicron forced
the grammys to change plans just weeks
before the broadcast they pushed the
awards back to april moved them from los
angeles here to las vegas and all that
made producing this incredibly complex
live show even more challenging
i think what we're trying to do this
year is is create still that intimacy
that we had last year where where it
doesn't feel like you're just in rows
and rows and rows of people yeah and
also you know you're near to this stage
over here because that's where people
are going to come up and get their
awards ben winston who ran the grammys
for the first time last year during the
pandemic has been reimagining the epic
awards show and so what we've done is
we've essentially it's smaller tables
there's sort of like four
tables with nice lights on them and
obviously that gives us the ability to
change the mood in the room we were
wondering what these were they're
speakers so you can hear what's going on
otherwise how would you able to i
thought that was like a camera was going
to be on everybody yeah no we're going
to film exactly everyone wants to know
what jay balvin's going to eat and so
we're just putting a little we're going
to be able to cut to what he eats at any
moment yeah no this is so you can hear
it is there a lot of politics that goes
into who you put where
there might be
there might be um there might be a bit
of politics there's been politics to
everything we're doing a show like this
there's politics to like you know who
goes where in the running order who sits
where what awards go where this is our
first day of our tech rehearsal and our
on stage rehearsals so is this is this
pretty hairy right now it's going to get
dicey co-executive producer janae rouzan
clay took us backstage this is kind of
our uh presenter walkout space we've got
a little bit of our set here
so all the sets come through back here
yes so we have 16 performances on the
show this year and all of them i should
say a good portion of them have huge
sets so they all have to be stored here
and then seamlessly move back and forth
to get them onto the stage i'm looking
we're behind the screens yes so this is
all electronics all electronic screens i
mean it's massive our set is completely
new this year
on that new set sunday brothers osborne
will be giving their first solo grammy's
performance
two grammy nominations performance big
night
news night yeah absolutely
lot a little bit of pressure too well
you're in a betting town how do you feel
about your eyes
i've never bet on myself yeah but i'm
always surprised though yeah i mean i
think that's also the beauty of being
able to perform because having that
opportunity on such a huge platform as
the grammys yeah it's a win already so
yeah there's going to be a lot to
celebrate now we've seen the grammys get
moved i mean how is it in the middle of
all this for you we really were praying
we're like oh my god we have this huge
opportunity this huge nomination and
this huge performance moment and then
there's someone moving the grammys
around i'm like if this doesn't happen
the grammys were moved this year to a
smaller venue the mgm grand garden arena
because of kovit you have to change
gears right in the middle of planning
for all this how much did that mess
things up for you it was i mean it was a
complete shift raj kapoor and jesse
collins are also on the executive
producing team how late into the process
are you still changing things i mean the
show's sunday yes um
we haven't
locked anything so we've got four
minutes figured out solid
then we got you know
three hours and then you're waiting
today we start seeing what people have
been working on for months there's acts
on our show that have more than a
hundred people so you know like j belvin
has 64 dancers right and then when you
put that with the stylists and the
artists and the creatives and their
video teams and it's like there's a
hundred people walking in in our door
for one performance yeah just for one
act yeah it's live tv anything can
happen yes it can you look at what
happened at the oscars yeah
did you worry about that of course yeah
of course i did it made me feel quite
sick
but i think it made everyone feel i
couldn't work out if i felt really sad
by it because we had this a week later
or just because it was a really sad
moment you know what it does it gives
you a little jolt of going we are going
into live tv here so what do we do if x
y and z happens yeah and i think it just
makes you have that conversation so that
you're more ready for things when it can
go right or wrong what is the most
intense and scary part of this show for
you
uh about a minute ago
i think a minute ago you feel like
you're walking off
a cliff edge and you don't know if
you're gonna fly or fall yeah my partner
in my company james corden said to me
recently about this show when he hosted
it and he said to me the downside of
doing this show is you say something
wrong and your career is over yes the
upside is seven nice emails afterwards
and i sort of get what he means and i
feel a similar way
being the producer of this show and one
of the producers of it is that like if
it goes wrong everyone will talk about
it yeah and if it goes really well
people go oh yeah good job yeah that's
right that's it
[Laughter]
it's so true if you've ever been in the
room for the grammys it's like watching
a small miracle happen there are so many
sets that have to be switched out in
seconds or minutes so many moving parts
so much that could go wrong and what's
remarkable guys is that it so rarely
does
that's good anthony what a great
producing team though you got jesse
collins ben winston is a super duper
producer you know anthony he produced
that whole adele thing he's got a very
good track record that's right but i was
i was wondering too the question you
asked they had to be a little nervous
based on what happened with the oscars
so the vibe in las vegas how do you
describe it compared to what you
normally see in in l.a
well it's la the whole town is excited i
got to tell you it's kind of weird
because like the guy who drove me here
this morning said why are you going to
the mgm grand and i said the grammys and
he goes the grammys are here
you know they've got a lot going on in
this town
yeah i do like what jesse collins said
though for people who don't know live tv
we've got about four minutes figured out
that is exactly how it happens
a lot to look forward to 16 live
performances vlad
yeah
they just i mean they literally started
rehearsals yesterday i mean that's the
thing that amazes me this whole show's
going live on sunday the first
performance rehearsals were yesterday
and you know they have to put it all
together in the next few days
i love seeing you and the brothers
osbournes together anthony because i
know you guys are really tight did you
ask tj about his new hair color
[Laughter]
no i didn't i was a little surprised too
gayle i have to tell you i'm so rooting
for them uh they're up for two awards
best country album best pop duo
performance fingers crossed for them i
love the other nominees too but i hope
they have a great year
i do too you do too anthony it's a
friday in las vegas don't rush home
exactly
stay enjoy the fun anthony mason thank
you very much as always